(mouse clicking)
(computer beeping)
(gentle piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained,
alone the master of
fire, tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(light music)
(bright music)
- There actually are no
chimpanzees in this image,
but I wanted to start
with it to remind you,
as both of our previous
speakers very nicely
and eloquently told you,
humans are hyper cooperative.
And in addition to the many ways
in which we depend on cooperation,
including for the construction
of auditoriums like this,
we also have, what I think
is compelling evidence
for an increase in meat consumption
from the paleo-archeological records,
starting by about two million years ago,
at for example this site of Kanjera South,
or several sites in
Kanjera in western Kenya,
where there's good evidence for hunting
of small to medium sized antelope
at about two million years,
and then later at Olduvai
and other sites in East Africa,
further evidence for an
increase in meat consumption,
including that image in
the upper right there,
of a recreation of presumably homo erectus
butchering a very large
animal, in that case,
probably scavenged not hunted but,
and then we have chimpanzees.
And chimpanzees are, along with bonobos,
the closest living relatives of humans,
and they eat more meat than
any other non-human primates.
So humans eat the most
meat of all primates,
but chimpanzees are second,
by quite a distance.
And when they hunt and succeed,
and when they have meat,
another resemblance to humans
is that they typically
engage in meat transfers.
And I use that term rather
than they share meat,
or food sharing, because we
might want to reserve sharing
for peaceful exchanges of meat,
but meat is not always,
individuals who don't have meat
don't always get it peacefully.
This is, there are various categorizations
of food transfers, and this is most of one
that Andreas Jaeggi and Carl van Schaik
used a few years ago, in
which they distinguished,
first of all, forced transfers
that involve aggression, so meat theft,
or prey theft, and then
a transfer that happens,
but it happens passively, which is to say
that someone possesses
meat and someone else
takes some of it peacefully or maybe
with some minor aggression and resistance
and some degree of tolerance,
varying degrees of tolerance
by the possessor, and then
there's what they called
reactive transfers, that
is someone possesses
some meat and someone else
requests or begs for meat,
and the possessor then makes it available
by something like that, and
then there's really true
proactive sharing, where
someone has some meat
and of its own accord offers
it to another individual.
And here is a sequence of an attempt
at getting a passive transfer.
This is an adult male chimpanzee at Ngogo
who is in possession of about half
an adult female red colobus monkey
and this is an adolescent
male who is hoping
to get some of that
meat, and very patiently
sitting there like this,
afraid actually to try
to touch it, he did get meat eventually,
and in fact, eventually the adult male
handed him a piece of meat.
Just to complicate matters slightly,
to simplify matters slightly,
I'm just going to talk
about active and passive sharing.
So active sharing or active transfers,
the possessor actually offers
the meat to someone else
and passive transfer is someone has meat
and allows someone else to take some,
but that'll complicate things slightly
by talking also about
what I call co-feeding.
Where someone clearly controls some meat,
in this case, that male controls
half a blue monkey,
here this male controls
an adult female red colobus monkey,
and there, that male controls
this yearling red duiker.
And as long as they have firm control,
they are comfortable letting
others take what they want.
So, make contact with the
carcass or with the meat package,
even feed from it directly
or tear pieces off,
so long as they don't try
to take the entire thing.
There have been a number,
I should say first of all,
that when it does come to the question
of why do chimpanzees hunt,
I think as Ian explained,
they hunt because meat is good food.
But because meat is
nutritionally so valuable,
that then opens possibilities for meat
to take on social importance.
It may be that actually transfers
don't have great social importance,
even though they involve
social interaction,
because what's going on
is that someone, again, has meat,
they are trying to eat it and someone else
is trying to get some of
it, and harassing them,
and they can, the possessor can improve
usually his foraging
efficiency, his ability
to use the meat, by simply
giving into the pressure
and allowing someone
else to take some of it.
Also, there are diminishing returns
to someone who has acquired the meat
and perhaps has a large amount of it,
and has already been
feeding on it for awhile,
when someone else comes along
and asks for some of it.
It's also possible though, if that meat
assumes an important role via exchanges,
either meat for meat, so if
one chimp has meat now today,
and allows someone else to have some
or even gives some to
that other individual,
then in return, again, usually
he will be able to get meat
in the future when they don't have some,
and the recipient does.
And it's also possible
that they exchange meat
for other things, notably grooming
between males especially,
and also coalitionary support
between males and then there is this idea
that males could exchange meat for matings
with females, and in
that case, transfers are,
to some extent actually contingent.
They're made selectively
to certain partners,
and then received in return,
selectively from certain partners.
These are not mutually
exclusive possibilities,
and in fact, from, based
on what I see at Ngogo,
I would say that sometimes individuals
get meat by harassing whoever has it,
and the chimpanzee being harassed
might try to avoid the beggar,
but eventually just gives in,
allows them to have some meat,
but that does not rule out the possibility
that they also use meat strategically
as a kind of social tool.
Clearly, the recipients of meat get
nutritional benefits from obtaining it.
The question here is,
do the donors benefit
from allowing others to
have some of the meat,
and if it's a question of tolerated theft
or harassment, the benefit,
again, might simply be
that I have some meat, and
by allowing someone else
to take it, I can now utilize what I have
more efficiently, because
I don't have to deal
with the harassment, and possibly the risk
that if I don't allow them to have it,
they'll try to steal all of it.
When it comes to possible social benefits,
again, there are various possibilities.
Reciprocity in meat transfers,
so pairs of individuals
showing some balance
in how often each can
get meat from the other
when the other has meat,
also, male chimpanzees
resemble humans in that
males, and differ from
almost all other mammals, in that males
form very strong social
bonds with each other,
and they depend on each other,
they cooperate in various ways.
They also spend extended periods of time
grooming with each other and
grooming provides hygienic
benefits, it also can provide
other health related benefits
via its calming effects.
In addition, males
sometimes form coalitions
with each other to back each other up
in contests with third parties,
and when they do that often enough
and reciprocally, we call them allies.
So here, for example, you
see two former alpha males
at Ngogo, who were each other's allies
for a long period of time.
Initially, he backed him
up when he was alpha male,
and then when things had switched,
he, Mweya, backed up
Bartok, who had replaced him
with one intervening male as alpha male.
So males need social partners in contacts
other than hunts or meat
sharing opportunities,
and they need partners for grooming,
or certainly can benefit
from having partners
for coalitionary support,
and all the males
of a given community are
allies with each other
against outsiders, and relations
between neighboring chimpanzee communities
are intensely hostile, which
is a topic for another talk.
Not all partners, not
all potential partners
are equally valuable, and we could expect
that male chimpanzee
psychology has been subject
to selection for tolerance generally,
at least towards familiar
male chimpanzees,
and for higher tolerance
towards valuable partners.
And that would then provide a basis
for selectively transferring
meat to valuable partners.
It might sound a little strange
to talk about male
chimpanzees as being tolerant,
but again, compared to
males in other mammals
other than humans, they are.
And this is an intriguing indication
that desperately needs replication.
That there is something going on socially,
a paper by Roman Wittig and colleagues
came out a few years ago in
which they managed to get
a small number of urine samples
following meat transfer events
and they did assays for oxytocin
which is a hormone that is arguably
involved in social
bonding, in reducing fear
and potentially promoting
cooperation in various ways,
and they found that oxytocin levels
were higher after meat transfers
than in other contexts,
including even when
individuals had been grooming
with each other or than when
they had been feeding socially,
that is, in a group with other chimps,
but no transfers of food.
And the authors here propose
that sharing of food,
and this was not just meat, in fact,
they had few cases of meat transfers,
which is one reason why
this needs replication.
But they proposed that sharing food
is, can provide a basis for cooperation.
Alternatively, but not
mutually exclusively,
it could be that we find
that close social partners
get food from each other relatively often,
but it's just because
they're more comfortable
with each other, so someone is more likely
to approach a meat
possessor if he already is
a close social partner
and then via harassing
the partner or tolerated theft,
gets some meat from them.
If that's the case, though,
we wouldn't expect to see
variation in begging success as a function
of partner value, nor would
we expect similar variation
in active sharing or in the amount of meat
that beggars acquire,
so I'm going to take us
now to Ngogo for awhile.
Ngogo is one of several research sites
in Kibale National Park in western Uganda,
at three of which there are
chimpanzee research projects.
And in Kibale National Park
there are seven species
of diurnal primates, not
all of them shown here,
and also small forest
antelope like red duiker,
all of the animals in this image are prey
for chimpanzees, but as Ian told you,
mostly they prey on red colobus monkeys.
And this is the results of about
2,800 some bouts of begging, that is,
one individual trying to get meat
from someone else and
in most cases, actually,
succeeding, in the
great majority of cases,
although there's some
interesting variation.
For example, females are
less likely to get meat
from males who are the major possessors
than other males are
to get meat from them.
And sometimes a transfer is made
because someone steals meat
from someone else, so theft.
What stands, and in most
cases, it's passive transfer,
so that's what's been reported
for other chimpanzee sites,
but one thing that stands out here
is that quite a few of
the transfers are active.
That is, someone else, someone offers meat
to someone else, and they
could choose not to do that.
And when I looked at the
results of all the attempts
to get meat, and then put that together
with data for a given study period
on how much grooming the
possessor got from whoever
was begging for meat, it
turned out that the likelihood
of getting meat went up as the amount
of grooming that the
possessor was receiving from,
not at the moment, but in general,
from the beggar went up, so
more likely to transfer meat
to mean grooming partners
than to other males.
And, this doesn't look so dramatic,
but I'll make a more
dramatic point in a moment.
Males are also more likely to allow
their allies to have
meat than they are males
who are not currently their allies.
Importantly, they're more
likely to give their allies
meat than they are to
give other males meat.
So this is the big difference here,
active sharing much more
common between males
who are allies of each other
than between males who aren't.
Also, males who groom
meat possessors a lot
are more likely to get large
shares of meat from them
and a large share is this
kind of a fuzzy definition,
but a small share would be
a small piece of a carcass,
and maybe just a small scrap of meat.
A large share would be
something like an entire limb
or half an adult female
red colobus monkey,
and actually transfer of large shares
is quite common at Ngogo,
again they go more often
to top grooming partners
than to other males
who are not top grooming partners.
And they particularly go to allies.
So again, this difference
here, fairly close to half
of the bouts with transfers between allies
involved one male getting
a large share of meat
from the other, and it's
a considerable amount
in other bouts also, but not so common
between males who are not allies.
Back to females, and there's
a lot more to be said
about females, I'll just briefly
cover this one hypothesis
which has been called for better or worse,
meat for sex, and I don't have
time to go into the details
of the chimpanzee mating system here,
it's quite complicated,
but most mating takes place
in situations where a
female is sexually receptive
and is with multiple males
and has an opportunity
to mate with all or most or all of them
and it doesn't make any difference
whether a female is sexually receptive
when it comes to the odds
that she gets meat from males.
This is new data from
Ngogo, but it substantiates
what we've already said about Ngogo,
and what Ian and colleagues
have said about Gombe.
So just to tie together a few things here,
that I think makes it clear
that data from chimpanzees
don't support arguments
that meat provisioning
formed part of hominin
male mating strategies,
prior to substantial increases in hunting
and meat consumption and real dependence
on meat consumption for subsistence.
More importantly though,
I think that chimpanzee
hunting and meat sharing, despite all
of the differences from
humans, some of which,
again, we heard about earlier today,
do tell us, and probably
have something important
to tell us about the
psychology of tolerance
and cooperation that underlies obligatory
hyper cooperation in humans.
So, thank you.
(audience applauds)
(bright music)